[Música]
en muchos momentos de mi vida
he sentido que no puedo más
la tigra tienen agua al sur de este país
y a temprana edad mi hermano mayor y yo
fuimos diagnosticados con una condición
genética
nuestros huesos son comparados a un
cristal por su nivel de fragilidad
tantas veces
y
van a decir que le corten otra formación
mis actividades no fueron muy enfadados
con los demás niños
hace años
en vez de recibir una bicicleta unos
patines
a la medida para que aprendiera comidas
fue hasta verdad pero ocho años que
finalmente ingresados vuelan
y crecí apartar
sé que en muchos casos se aportaban por
amor
por temor a que algo me pasara
en muchos otros casos fui a patadas
porque soy diferente
pero botas
en los que yo decidí a faltar
porque memoria de la tristeza
cada vez que la que las personas
desde los 10 años hasta los 17 estuve
libre de facturas
y a esta edad misionera
venir a estudiar en la universidad para
salir adelante
sin embargo la ley page
por el sedentarismo
y mis huesos empezaron a deformar
ustedes pueden imaginar
que tu propio pecho tenga la capacidad
de reformar tus huesos
juega tipo
y de hecho se convirtió en una curva
y aunque inicie dieta estaba con sal
sabía caminar
de cali
solo que esta vez fue diferente
alguna fractura
no olvida para ver el fútbol en dos
partes y seleccione las rodillas
para hacer estar independiente al
siquiera poder comer por mí mismo
y con esta calidad no sólo sean los
villanos varios de mis huesos sino que
mi vida literalmente se ve todo
no comía no podía no quería ver a nadie
quería en muchas ocasiones no preguntar
por qué a mí por qué
porque debía pasar por todo eso
nuevamente
fue hasta varios medios después que me
doy cuenta que la vida seguía marchando
perfectamente
y qué calles de 'la para toda la vida
nuestra sin límites
pueden hacer dos cosas
que tenemos que ayudarnos creativos
o me quedaba llorando por todo lo que yo
había perdido
a su día que mi situación actual
y confiaba en que los planes de dios
eran mejores que los unidos
si el plan no funciona también la
8 - en cama y varias intervenciones
quirúrgicas
les pidieron que terminara la secundaria
a pesar de todos los colores
y en el 2009 vienen como mínimo
con todos mis sueños
con un solo cuando están juntos
un guardado
a todos aquellos que me conocen
y que se preguntaba cómo iba a venir una
muchacha que no podía caminar
de lo mismo experto del andador
y la entrevista
porque me trepaba a todas partes andando
sobre mi face papá
las minas y las cosas
pero a pesar de la universidad no lo
podrán hacer estuvo aquí porque no está
mal
cuatro años después
[Aplausos]
con mi título universitario vinieron
otros desafíos
se entendía que dar poco probable
también
[Música]
con un bastón
tuve entrevistas que miraban en el
pastor
otras que abiertamente expresamos
empezar a poner por verme caminar
porque en la misma medida que muchas
puertas
ahora
hoy día de la labor
y tengo casi 8 años de experiencia
trabajando
[Aplausos]
cada vez que etiqueta y me mostraba a mí
misma que era un diagnóstico médico las
opiniones de los espectadores y un
bastón define las capacidades que como
persona
pero uno que hizo que mi perspectiva
cambiada
la zona lecciones la rodilla y por
recomendaciones médicas intentó
inscribir las escapadas una ocasión
me dijeron que no me podían inscribir
porque iba a trabajar
a cambio me dije
y las personas con discapacidad
podrían optar por las terapias que ellos
ofrecían
voy a insistir
y admiten en las frases grupales
hasta el momento yo estaba acostumbrada
a la forma
pero esta vez me hizo un experto
falta todavía ir a marte
o mi condición físicamente
al primer contacto con el agua
yo sentí como mis extremidades se
cobraban vida dentro de la piscina
yo sentí sensaciones que yo no conocía
y movimientos que yo nunca fui capaz
y así fue
y madres
durante las plantas me dejaban de voz
me apartaba y sonido permití apollinaire
sintiéndome estancada y frustrada por no
aprender decir o agregar horas
adicionales a la cocina
no me conforme con lo que era momento
para decir no busque excusas
estas nuevas claves me encontré con un
profesor que creía que no podía aprender
y con compañeras que me hacían sentir
igual
nadie me veía con una discapacidad allí
y fue el primer lugar
donde no existe sin el bastón
y él espera
en vez de evolucionar
y siete meses después
empecé a entrenar todos los días con un
equipo convencional y áfrica para
sacarme para competir
la mejor manera de evitar que los
estereotipos desfilando
esta nuestra que no son ciertas las
ideas que tienen sobre ti
nadie dado que no sea admisible
me hice
y como lo mismo
volviendo con las etiquetas de la
estructura por el bastón
sabía que son mucho más que los frágiles
que podía
no solamente su fortalecimiento el cual
sino que también iba a fortaleciendo
y es curioso como como este sentimiento
ministro pasa a entrenar dos horas
alrededor de 25 horas
por su mano
a entrenar
cualquiera podría aterrizar que me
dedico 100 a esto pero lo cierto es que
trabajo a tiempo completo me dieron muy
bien
lo que para mí
lo que para muchos ha sido una excepción
para mi vida
porque no recuerdo un momento en el que
d
cuando estoy
esta chica en 2015 no sabía nadar
y la que desarrollamos
en verano este año los paracos militamos
y se convirtió en la primera y única de
la nación dominicana en un evento de
este tipo
y hoy está preparando
[Aplausos]
a través de la discapacidad
es más lo que gana
color de rosa pero de nosotros te pediré
dejar que una percepción nos defina
ahora tomarnos a nosotros mismos quienes
somos de qué estamos hechos y de que
hemos tomado
en el momento en que entendí que sólo
los pies de los 90 de ellos necesitan
encajar en un lugar en este momento de
generar lo que empecé
a convertir mis debilidades importantes
lo negativo es posibilidad
a saber que puede
al borde de misiles es donde realmente
con esta historia
y para los más allá de nuestros límites
y permitamos soñar y alcanzar nuestros
sueños
[Aplausos]
los retos los obstáculos los desafíos
siempre estarán ahí pero como dice mi
entrenador antes de cada carrera sonría
y discutan porque el resultado dependerá
de comenzar enteros las eventualidades
que aparecen alimentando
el deporte de los últimos días
también mi perspectiva de la vid
me dio ganas me dio amigos me dió una
familia pero lo más importante
me dio posibilidades
tenía yo quería volar
y bueno
hola
[Aplausos]
[Música]